[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
good morning please be seated
[Applause]
good morning to everybody welcome to
this recognition ceremony for the 757
incredible members of the class of 2019
give yourselves a round of applause let
me be the first person up here to offer
you special congratulations today from
everyone in the Columbia Business School
family I have personally enjoyed working
with many of you in class you're very
special to me because you are the last
set of hands I'll have the pleasure of
shaking as Dean so so I promise to try
to get it right now collectively your
class is extraordinary and
extraordinarily diverse you come from 57
different countries as far as Brazil
Lebanon Switzerland in the Philippines
okay you speak 45 different languages
and dialects including finish Tamil Thai
Ukrainian Yoruba and people tell me
English you come from countless
industries and professional backgrounds
and among you are of course consultants
and financiers but also hikers
beekeepers Bollywood dancers
powerlifters world travelers and
entrepreneurs of every stripe I hope you
take pride in all that you have
accomplished and indeed three of you
have done exceptionally well
academically during your time at school
and our graduating I said exceptionally
you've all done well and are graduating
with a grade point average of 10 point o
or higher congrats for the
no today today this morning you join a
new community a vibrant community of
alumni who are decision makers and
leaders at the center of business
they're entrepreneurs they're Industry
pioneers and game changers a network of
forty six thousand five hundred
individuals who do both influential and
important work that changes the world
you've been of course working toward
fulfilling that role since the day you
got here for orientation we all
challenged you to be active to be
engaged members of the community I know
I speak for all my faculty colleagues in
seeing you have more than met this
challenge as students on campus whether
by serving your classmates through
formal channels like the peer advisor
program and student government or
playing a role in the successful
execution of Columbia forever or women's
week lending an invaluable voice at club
meetings and events or just sharing your
ideas about your MBA experience
collectively today is the moment we set
aside so that we in the faculty and
administration at Columbia Business
School together with your family and
your friends can celebrate you and your
accomplishments and wish you continued
success I know you leave the school well
equipped as leaders as thinkers ready to
have a real impact and I look forward to
seeing the change you'll make in your
professional lives and in your
communities and I'd like you to take a
moment to acknowledge with your applause
the people who have supported your time
here in particular your friends and
family and everyone here who's worked
with you
[Applause]
individually you've been exposed to
thought leadership that is always
informed in real time by the business
world around us research from the
school's faculty influences the practice
of business in every sector the
curriculum you have seen has taught you
to be able to create an opportunity in
any environment and thanks to our
physical position here in New York you
have been able to see myriad industries
and visionary business leaders on campus
and in high-impact internships in every
possible industry the reputation the
strength of Columbia Business School has
equipped you with the knowledge and
access you will need to continue to make
the impact you make in business and
beyond as an alum that reputation that
strength will continue to provide you
with connections and support they help
foster the creativity I know is in you
invite entrepreneurial thinking and open
more doors you couldn't be better
prepared but I have to tell you and
share with you what makes me proudest to
be your Dean it's to remind you that
with the rewards of your MBA and I hope
and believe they will be substantial for
you also comes responsibility what does
it really mean to be a graduate of a
school like Columbia Business School we
all hope and expect that you recall that
we are and have always been a place
that's in the business of value and
values yes we are proud to be the
birthplace of value investing like okay
some fans out there my my colleagues and
I certainly strive to add value in all
disciplines but I want you to remember
today that personal values matter and
matter most in the workplace and in your
broader life so as you rise in your
career remember all the discussions
you've had here in leadership and ethics
which I hope inspire you to give back in
your community writ large and the
students here as they come up as you did
in the Columbia Business School spirit
fortunately you have so many
extraordinary examples to follow in your
fellow alumni just thinking back even
over my time as Dean I think of alumni
like Donnell Baird
his company blocked power trains
unconventional employees to install
energy efficient technology for small
businesses not-for-profits in
underserved communities slashing both
energy costs a good thing in business
and co2 emissions a good thing socially
in 2012 just before he graduated here he
received the echoing green and Open
Society Foundations black male
achievement fellowship which supports
work to improve life outcomes for
African American men another example
Shazi visceral class of 2004 Shazi
founded happy family it's the leading
premium organic baby and toddler food
brand in America before it's sale it
ranked number two among food and
beverages companies generally in inks
magazine Inc magazines annual listing of
the 500 fastest growing companies the
same year the magazine named Shazi among
its 10 best female entrepreneurs she
launched the idea in business school now
serves on the school board and sold the
stake she had an happy family to Danone
meanwhile also in those years when John
Stein class of Oh 9 was just a novice
investor he thought he could do better
than what his economics professors had
drilled into him that's a dangerous
thought when you ever have that the
thought he wanted to reject was that the
market portfolio was the optimal one so
after his first stock pick which was
Enron failed and after deciding the
finally he'd economists advice he
created Betterman an online investment
advisor which offers consumers a better
a more convenient way to invest in the
market portfolio the company's been
dubbed the Apple of Finance and today is
four hundred thousand customers who've
invested more than 16 billion dollars
more broadly over a longer period
you might think of Gerry spire or Li
Cooperman or Henry Kravis Lulu Wong
Robert Smith Russ Carson Shelley Lazarus
Tracy Travis art Samberg Warren Buffett
Jerry Chazen Vikram Pandit James Gorman
Jaime Kern Lima Tim campus or any of
46,500
amazing men and women those names that
community that network is yours it's an
asset like all assets I encourage you to
stay connected to it and to consume its
returns so what really happens this
morning
what's the special magic in one sense
the familiar sense you're going to
graduate you will become part of that
alumni network that I just described you
go from being a student to making your
further mark in the world like Mariam
vana Karim will be presented Wednesday
with the Alumni medal for service to the
entire university it's with precisely
these thoughts in mind that we celebrate
your graduation from a great business
school today this is a world-class
institution that marries what we do in
the university scholarship theory new
frontiers of knowledge with real-world
business practice in a community of
creative and diverse individuals I think
it's the honor of all of my colleagues
on the faculty to be able to work with
you and I'm particularly proud to be
your Dean but it's not the word
graduation that I have in mind today
it's easy to be reflective like that but
I prefer a more old-fashioned term for
what happens this morning and the term
is commencement and I like it because it
has an explicit reference to beginnings
this morning you will begin again a life
of engagement in business and society
you have much to contribute to both and
I know you will most of all most of all
never ever forget what a noble calling
business is and the power that lies
within each and every one of you to
transform not only the lives of
Anne Shiell statements and other
business leaders entrepreneurs but your
fellow alumni communities and nations
around the world never forget that your
MBA is really a master of choices what
matters most to all of us is not the
change jingling in your pocket after
commencement but the change you're about
to make in the world again give
yourselves a round of applause and
congratulations
it is now my great privilege to welcome
our distinguished speaker this morning
Carol SAW died I am proud to say class
of 1991 when all of you first arrived on
campus I think I and others encouraged
you to think like an entrepreneur what
we meant by that was seizing opportunity
whenever and wherever it may lie which
is precisely what Carol has done in her
career even when it means taking giant
leaps of faith and that's why she's a
great speaker for you today she started
her career at PricewaterhouseCoopers
where she served fortune 500 public
clients with a primary focus on media
and entertainment eleven years after
joining the firm she became a partner
obviously a moment of great pride but
six years later after the life-changing
events of September 11th she really R
and decided to leave the company for a
leadership role as CFO at the famous law
firm of Skadden Arps now leaving the
security of PwC in the long term fit is
of course a risk but it allowed her to
spend the next eight years making a
significant impact in a new place
leading exciting projects and serving on
a great executive team eight years later
she found herself joining the National
Basketball Association where she was CFO
an executive vice president during
pivotal moments in the NBA's history in
2012 after remaining in touch with her
PwC Network she was asked to rejoin the
company as CFO today after coming 360
full circle she's the chief operating
officer for PwC Network the leading
leading the entire network operations
driving the budgeting financial planning
and investments throughout the network
and collaborating with the entire global
leadership team her story can be your
story ultimately the goal of Columbia
Business School is for every graduate to
be an outstanding leader on a journey
like Carol taking risks pursuing passion
trusting in the journey please help me
welcome
Carol Soto
Wow I have to say this is awesome I mean
the energy in this room and in walking
seeing everybody walk in was just it was
humbling to me so thank you again for
asking me to do this and thank you dean
for that kind introduction and
congratulations to you on your 15 year
tenure as the head of this really
awesome institution so there's no
question that on his watch the Columbia
Business School has staked its rightful
place at the very center of business I
couldn't be prouder to call myself a
graduate so in today in just a few short
minutes 750 seven of you will join me in
that distinction so again
congratulations Dean Hubbard and
congratulations to the Columbia Business
School class of 2019
and to your parents spouses children
children on the way for many a few of
you and other loved ones celebrating
with you today they shared in the grind
these last couple of years and they now
get to share in the glory with you so
turn to your sides and turn around and
thank them as well
[Applause]
so I'm painfully aware that I stand
between you and that hard hard earned
MBA but I'm relishing having you as a
captive audience for a little bit I'll
try to be short but I'll try to give you
some insights as well so I have to admit
this is a cathartic moment for me my
life has really come full circle to the
time and place that really forged me as
a person when I walked the halls of
Urist some 30 years ago and by the way
it's hard to believe you're all still in
URIs Hall I was 25 on the fast track to
partnership at then price waterhouse
which sponsored my MBA then the walls
caved in I was diagnosed with cancer
Hodgkin's lymphoma after my first
semester here my doctors told me I had a
50/50 shot of surviving past 30 I didn't
quit school I didn't run away to an
ashram or go bungee jumping
I didn't chase miracle cures or exotic
clinical trials
I just turned towards the cancer I
confronted it head-on I showed up for
class and I showed up for chemo and in
1991 I'm very proud to say I graduated
with the rest of my cluster and got my
MBA
but I didn't have this moment I didn't
walk up to the podium to receive my
degree I was too spent to attend
graduation and that's why the invitation
to come here to speak and address you
today is so meaningful to me so I really
thank you
so candidly there aren't many advantages
to getting cancer especially at a young
age and I truly don't recommend it but
I'll tell you it has a way of focusing
the mind and crystallizing your
priorities and it really gave me a great
leg up on overcoming some principal
impediments to happiness and fulfillment
and that's fear I grew up in a very
conservative household my parents were
and are very practical people a chemist
and an engineer they'd always believed
in a strong work ethic a frugal
lifestyle and the avoidance of risk so
very important to them don't take
unnecessary risks so my career as an
accountant was essentially preordained
it took cancer for me to realize that
fear had been a guarding guiding force
in my life the guardrails on the
treadmill I was on fear of failure fear
of the unknown fear of dependence the
author in cartoonist James Thurber once
wrote all human beings should try and
learn before they die what they're
running from and to and why I want to
repeat that for you all human beings
should try and learn before they die
what they're running from and to and why
it's actually a marvelous exercise and
it doesn't require a life-threatening
illness so I recommend that to all of
you those of you sitting in front of me
in the light blue robes know what I'm
talking about
you made a conscious choice to step off
the treadmill when you applied to
Columbia Business School over two years
ago it was a risk mind you a calculated
one to be sure but you chose to further
your education and accept the sacrifices
personal professional and financial that
might entail I chose to do the same I
chose to round out my business
credentials and
fluor brought her career horizons by
gutting it out here first at Columbia
and I'm here to reassure you it was all
worth it about 10 years after completing
my treatment for Hodgkin's I left the
comfort and security of a partnership at
PwC to take a job as CFO of Skadden Arps
a prominent law firm it was truly an
eye-opening and extraordinary eight
years of experience where I ultimately
became the chief operating officer from
there I lept into the deep end of the
pool at the NBA as executive vice
president and CFO and a member of the
commissioners negotiation team for the
new collective bargaining agreement with
the players I'm proud to say that that
agreement is largely in place today so
this wasn't a slam dunk sorry I had to
make that pun in fact the job initially
was to financially prepare the league
and the teams for the worst case
scenario that we'd be out for at least a
full season but we got it done and it
stands out as one of my most rewarding
professional achievements I can honestly
say I would never have left PwC had I
not had the cancer scare and my life and
career would have been poorer for it so
now I'm back at PwC in a global
leadership role I might never have held
had I stayed the perspective and
experience I gained outside of the firm
actually enhanced my value within it and
they recruited me back so what's the
lesson here
life is short take calculated risks
embrace the unknown
these are commencement cliches I
understand but there's a pretty good
reason for that it's actually really
good advice but don't take away the
lesson cancer makes you special I know
I'm not alone here in dealing with a
cancer diagnosis either your own or that
of a loved one I would hazard to guess
in fact that the majority of the people
here have had some similar
but as the patient I can tell you and
fellow fellow survivors here will likely
agree you are alone and that's where my
advice becomes more Universal much as we
may be surrounded by love and support we
forge our life and career path alone and
that the only person that you and I
ultimately answer to is ourselves just
look in the mirror in the morning and
take note of who is looking back at you
and holding you accountable so be very
very conscious and deliberate about the
choices you make make sure they feel
right for you these are the choices that
will further your aspirations and your
happiness take it from me when I say
don't let fear steal your happiness I
almost did don't do it each and every
one of you came to Columbia Business
School for your own reasons
and you'll graduate with your own
learnings and ambitions your own dreams
and disappointments I know that teamwork
and collaboration we're woven into the
very fabric of your business school
experience as well they should be but
don't forget what makes you you and what
the privacy of your own thoughts you are
running from and to and why so seven
years ago at the age of 45
my husband John Oh a born and bred New
Yorker and successful media and
technology entrepreneur found his
calling as a restaurateur in Savannah
Georgia no less and a very successful
one at that you should actually google
it it's called the gray in your class
you have a world-class marathoner a
rugby player a boxer a ping-pong
champion there's a Eucharistic minister
and a rabbi and an NYPD auxilary police
officer artistic and musical talent
abounds in this room and we have a top
sommelier in the house yo Neela
we might want to talk afterwards I bet
you'd love the south this is clearly a
class that already knows there is more
that to life than work you have followed
your bliss and have already made real
impact in and on your communities the
best advice I can offer is to know
yourself pursue your passions be your
own best advocate and success will
follow stand on your own two feet but
there's a flip side to that you must
allow and encourage those you love to do
the same my job is in New York my
marriage is in Savannah we make it work
sort of I'm not sure my dog's otter and
anchovy always agree we sacrifice and
compromise what matters to us and our
relationship is the richer for it our
arms have been locked together for 27
years now you can't do it all you can't
have it all
you will suffer setbacks in addition to
battling cancer
my husband and I have lived through the
Northridge earthquake 9/11 hurricane
sandy and most recently yes the Paris
yellow vests protests we've lived
through some stuff and so will you think
of them all as learning moments so if
there's one quality I am an enormous fan
of one which I strongly encourage you to
cultivate its resilience at pwc we
introduced a program called be well work
well three years ago I'm a real champion
for this program because hard experience
has taught me the importance of
intentionally focusing on one's health
vul work well is all about encouraging a
culture of well-being in the workplace
across the four dimensions of energy
physical emotional mental and spiritual
but you don't need a corporate
sponsorship to focus on your well-being
after pooh-poohing much of this as a
young go-getter I'm a real convert now I
meditate every day I get eight hours of
sleep I walk to work five days a week I
practice gratitude and I reserve a lot
of time for laughing with my friends and
family you can't begin to care for love
or support others if you haven't
invested in your own wellness these are
the true ingredients of a good life so
to conclude let me congratulate you once
again on this seminal occasion you've
done it
relish and take pride in your
accomplishments and remember as you make
life and career choices from this day
forward what you're running from and to
and why thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much for those wonderful
words it is now my pleasure to introduce
our student speaker Briana Sadler not
class of 91 the class but class of 19
like Carol Breanna has also embraced
career twists and turns born and raised
in Jackson Mississippi where my father's
from Brianna earned a bachelor's degree
from Columbia University in 2014 she
intended to pursue a career in law or
academia but in the years following
graduation she became increasingly
interested in the intersection of
business and social impact leading her
to join decision Resources Group where
she specialized in consumer health
trends was that career move that was
also the impetus for her to pursue an
MBA at Columbia Business School Brianna
has served as co-president of cluster Q
the co-chair of CBS reflects and a peer
advisor
she's a laid low scholar a Columbia
Fellow and when she's not busy in the
classroom or at community events she
spends her time with LGBTQ advocacy
serving as a pro bono consultant for the
Brooklyn community pride Center and is a
steering committee member of the annual
out women in business conference after
graduation today Brianna will join a tea
carnie as an associate she's an
outstanding citizen of this community
and beyond so please join me in
welcoming Brianna to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Dean Hubbard for that kind
introduction and thank you to Carol for
joining us today thank you to my
classmates for giving me the opportunity
to speak on your behalf today this is no
doubt a momentous occasion a book end or
a bookmark in many ways the end of one
chapter and the beginning of a new one
and because of that it would be tempting
to imbue my speech with platitudes with
something to placate you all my fellow
graduates our esteemed faculty and
administration and all of the friends
and families gathered here today perhaps
I would parrot something like the world
is your oyster or the future it belongs
to you but the truth is the world is not
your oyster and despite what you may
think your future does not solely belong
to you
while a Columbia Business School
Education has no doubt cracked open and
exposed a whole new world of opportunity
the world is still not ours it is still
not yours to have or to take you see the
world it belongs to many other people as
well and the future it greatly depends
on how all people most of whom are not
Columbia Business School graduates how
they partake in it even beyond that the
future depends on our capacity as
graduates of this school to engage
empathetically with each other and with
those around us but simply put empathy
is hard it requires us to be an
extension of ourselves and perhaps what
is most frightening about it is that it
has the
City to contort our own realities beyond
recognition
it has the potential to fundamentally
shift our worldview to reframe every
aspect of our lives no doubt it is much
safer much easier and in many ways much
more pleasant to remain within the
confines of our own psyches comforted by
our own narrow perception of the world
by its truth and by its realities
the irony is hardly lost on me that this
morning I am the one test was speaking
to and for this graduating class I'm the
person with the singular responsibility
of representing all of you when quite
frankly I as the only gay black woman at
this school for the past two years I
have so often felt like none of you and
because of that here on this campus I
have spent a lot of time thinking about
empathy and difference and more
specifically how empathy with all of its
power to contort to shift to reframe how
empathy can work to span seemingly
impassable gulfs of difference I like
all of you stepped on to this campus
brimming with excitement with
anticipation and when I first saw our
peer advisors lined up outside of URIs
Hall screaming in our faces at 8 a.m. I
was also a bit apprehensive I like all
of you had familiarized myself with
everything that Columbia Business School
had to offer from classes to clubs and
everything in between I like all of you
also doubt if our new campus will be
built anytime in the next 50 years
but also like the poet nyira Wahid I am
increasingly wary and sceptical of
anyone who says that they do not see
color or gender or religion or
socioeconomic status or a country of
origin it means that to that person you
are invisible because while we share a
common thread a common experience while
we have shared our stories with one
another and collectively created
entirely new ones we are all 757 of us
wholly different people with identities
and idiosyncrasies and complexities that
are so central to who we are and more
importantly to who we can become back in
the fall as I was beginning to step into
my role as co-chair of CBS reflects our
diversity equity inclusion board a
classmate referencing the results of the
CBS reflects annual survey asked me
about the experiences of black women on
this campus specifically he asked why
compared to most other students black
student black women felt largely out of
place and less satisfied with their
experience at CBS at first
exasperated I brushed off his question
eager to move along with my day
truthfully despite having these
conversations constantly I often become
paralyzed by them because I am hesitant
to speak on behalf of all black women
because I am afraid of losing nuance and
these discussions and because I am more
afraid still of encountering someone who
is dead set on discounting how I feel
but to my surprise he politely pressed
on he did not shy away from the tension
or from the mounting emotion as our
conversation evolved he
held my narrative alongside his and he
delved deeper respectfully peeling back
the layers of my experience he did not
poke or prod or a question with the
intent of discounting quite the opposite
he listened and I I tried to do the same
in that moment we realized that his
truth and my truth could coexist that
our realities though different were
equally valid not because our experience
as his as a white Italian guy from
Jersey and mine as a black lesbian from
Mississippi were even remotely similar
or because we agreed on everything but
because we realized that no one voice
neither his nor mine held all the
answers in the process and pushing
through the discomfort and finding those
small moments of connection we emerged
three hours after first starting our
discussion with a better framework for
thinking about how our differences could
feel more like similarities
sometimes those moments of empathy of
reaching across goals of difference
they happened just like that and
sometimes they happen in the nooks and
crannies and those fleeting and tangible
moments during the spirited conversation
at a supper club or in the thunderous
applause after a classmate shares a
piece of their story a piece of
themselves during their CBS matters it
happens and the hushed muted whispers of
support when passing each other and our
beloved URIs halt and sometimes it
happens quickly loudly as jarring as a
clap of thunder that awakens you as if
from a bad dream it happens when we
together as a community must confront
and re-examine head-on how we think
about sexual respects and community
citizenship on this campus it happens
when we suddenly
unexpectedly lose a classmate and
together we mourn for everything we knew
about him and for all of the individual
pieces and stories of him that we loved
believe me when I say there is power so
much power and simply existing in spaces
that were not built for you from that
comes an opportunity to recreate them to
break them down to shake them up and to
rebuild them so that they are for you
or better yet as my classmate did you
can seek to better understand so that
you can help build those spaces for
other people as well when we leave this
place we will all be in positions of
power and privilege regardless of
whether you like me grow up from humble
southern beginnings or whether you grew
up from wealthy metropolitan ones you
will have the opportunity and the
responsibility to ask not what you can
take for yourself but what you can build
for others because business that is not
grounded in empathy becomes stale and
useless it makes us more susceptible to
reckless greed and arrogance it inhibits
our awareness our judgments and perhaps
most frightening of all to me it
inhibits our imaginations it risks
making us more of a liability than an
asset I am so glad that our capacity for
learning is not static that what we
think we know now even after reading
hundreds of cases and after traveling
thousands of miles over the past two
years is not all that we are capable of
learning or all that we are capable of
unlearning just as we have conceived of
new companies of new clubs of new
initiatives here on this campus as we
leave this place we are also free to
rican sieve and reimagine what it means
to be a bit
this leader who engages with others with
each other with empathy with empathy
with understanding and with perspective
to be someone who gives acknowledgement
devoid of judgment to be someone who
suspends preconceptions which are more
often than not misconceptions to be
someone who does not deny deflect or
diminish the thoughts and concerns of
others as foreign or as distant as they
may seem no I am quite bullish about our
future I count myself among the eternal
optimist forever believing in the
unbounded empathy of the human heart
forever believing and our ability to
recognize that our realities and thus
our futures are inexorably intertwined
with those around us forever believing
that the strongest currency that we will
ever hold or exchange is our capacity to
be kind with each other and to listen to
each other for ever believing that all
all of us all 750 seven of us are
collective shareholders of this
experience task not with creating value
just for ourselves but for creating
value for everyone else as well I stand
here today forever believing that to
engage with empathy to lead with empathy
to actively seek out new different and
often uncomfortable perspectives that
contort that shift that reframe our
lives that that is to ultimately profit
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much Briana for your
thoughtful and powerful message to your
peers Breanna Sadler good morning class
of 2019 I am pleased to start our
presentation of faculty and staff Awards
I'm pleased to present two student
nominated Awards the Robert W Lee reward
and the Singhvi prize for scholarship in
the classroom these two awards reflect
the values of inclusion and recognition
within the Columbia Business School
community the first is the Robert W Lear
Service Award
the Lera Ward is nominated by the
student body and presented to a faculty
member or administrator for the service
to the students above and beyond the
call of duty this year's award recipient
is Professor Bruce uh sure
he doesn't know I'm actually gonna say a
few words about him so I'm going to
embarrass him while he stands Professor
Asher masterfully walk students through
productive discussions on complicated
topics such as carbon offsets and
deforestation he has command of the
classroom and keeps people engaged by
conveying the urgency of problems that
may sometimes feel far-off he also takes
time to get to know students their names
and their interests professor utter uh
sure teaches through personal experience
in practice as a leader and impact
investing space and has a deep
commitment to making the world a better
place through this through his
leadership of the taymyr Center for
social enterprise he also co-led the
very popular and eye-opening course
bridging the American divide please join
me in congratulating Professor Bruce
[Applause]
the next award is the sing V prize for
scholarship in the classroom the sing V
prize is nominated by graduating
students and is awarded to a full-time
faculty member who exemplifies
excellence in the classroom based on his
or her dedication to teaching and
ability to communicate knowledge and
encourage students this year's recipient
is Professor Todd chick
[Applause]
verbatim feedback from students
professor jig is a familiar face for all
students since we learned in orientation
how we can push ourselves to thoroughly
evaluate and defend our reasoning if
you're lucky if you are lucky enough to
take his class you walk away with
lessons on culture and restructuring
that can help in all industries he gets
to know students and commands the
classroom he always asked you to bring
your a-game he's also a jokester who
knows how to strike the balance for
restless MBA students you all said this
not me Professor jig is also a great
citizen in the Columbia Business School
community he is a master classroom
facilitator he builds incredibly strong
relationships and as a matter of fact I
think he's currently overseeing five
independent studies professor Jick also
led a chastened course to Israel and
also co-led the bridging the American
divide with professor rusher please join
me in congratulating professor taja
excuse me as we conclude the faculty
Awards I'd like to take a moment to just
thank one more faculty member and that's
Dean Hubbard as you all know after 15
years a serving of dean of the business
school Glenn I can call you Glenn we're
friends
Glenn will be stepping down at the end
of June
so as you all walk across the stage and
he shakes your hand this will be his
last graduation as Dean of Columbia
Business School thank you for teaching
entrepreneurial finance not finance
thank you for raising the profile of
Columbia Business School thank you for
the hundreds and thousands of miles you
have logged traveling the US and the
world
raising money for financial aid and the
ever-elusive Manhattanville coming to a
campus near you in January of 2020 to
thank you for supporting the best and
brightest faculty staff and students
thank you for hiring me to be the Dean
of Students I have a few more gray hairs
but I am grateful for the opportunity to
work with the best team in the Office of
Student Affairs and the best students on
the planet last but not least from
Follies past present and future Thank
You Dean Hubbard Glen hobby hubs
for always being such a great sport and
as you CLECs it as you Glac sit we thank
you for your unwavering support and
dedication to students and the entire
CBS community
I am pleased to continue the award
presentation by recognizing the students
and recipients for community and service
awards Columbia Business School is proud
to recognize the recipients of the
following the New York City Alumni Award
given to a student in the top 10% of
their class on the basis of exceptional
academic achievement outstanding
character participation in school
affairs and potential for civic business
and professional leadership this year's
New York alumni recipient is Evan
Einstein
[Applause]
the Heffernan award for service is given
to graduating students who served the
school behind the scenes and contributed
to the academic standards operations
spirit and integrity of the Business
School these awards are selected by the
administration the Business School
Service Award Student Service Award
honoring students who have made
outstanding contributions to business
school community as selected by the
graduating class I'll announce those
next first the heifer noon Award for
service is presented to Beaulieu a day
yay
[Applause]
Kristen Cummins
Jacinta James Joe Lynch Tyrone CEO
and Katie - Sanchez
recipients for both the Heffernan award
for service and the business school
award are Xena
Hassan Rianna
Sadler
and the always happy Zack stone
recipients for the business school
service award are Raul ghoul sunshine
Lana
Cindy chin
[Applause]
ken Ren
Estie bellies Ruiz Gutierrez Lindy gold
and Jeff silver
the remaining service awards are
selected by the first year class the
outstanding teaching assistant award is
giving recognition to a student who
provided outstanding skill care and
involvement in presenting in class
material presenting class material this
year's recipient is devyani Cathar he
new this year is the excellence in
tutoring award which is given in
recognition of a student's outstanding
kill skill care and involvement
sometimes it skill in the tutoring
program this year's recipient is Sandra
Lucia now I'd like to begin the
presentation of academic awards the
following three awards will be presented
by Professor Wei Zheng the Amina Elliott
Webster Memorial Award in marketing this
award is presented to a graduating woman
who has shown overall academic
excellence in the area of marketing this
year's recipient recipient is Charlotte
Porter
the Eli Ginsberg Memorial Prize award is
presented annually to a graduating
student who has done outstanding work in
the field of economics or human
resources
this year's recipient come on down is
Bora Kepler
man he was excited about economics this
year the Suresh Bala Raman prize this
award is presented annually to a
graduating student who has demonstrated
outstanding work in the field of Finance
this year's recipient is Catherine bid
Kowski
[Applause]
[Music]
now presented by Professor Penman the
Robert and Jacqueline Whillans tax
research project award this award is
presented for superior skills in the
area of tax theory and practice or
research this year's recipient is Lauren
smear
also presented by Professor penguin the
Robert H Montgomery prize and accounting
this award is presented for excellence
in the area of accounting this year's
recipient is Mark Koontz
presented by Professor Todd Jack the
award for academic excellence in
decision risk and operations this award
is presented annually to a graduating
student who has demonstrated outstanding
work in the field this year's recipient
is
Venkata our Mathare LaRue also presented
by Professor Taj ik the award for
academic excellence in management this
award is presented annually to a
graduating student who has demonstrated
outstanding work in the field this
year's recipient is Zachary
Gober
[Applause]
presented by Professor Bruce uh sure
our two Award recipients for the Nathan
cancer prize for social enterprise this
award is presented annually to
graduating students who best demonstrate
leadership and dedication to social
enterprise and who have made outstanding
contribution contributions to the
community at Columbia Business School
and beyond this year's recipients are
Colette Soloff and Carly rah also
presented by Professor Bruce uh sure
as the Schumann Hubert award in
marketing this award is presented
annually to a graduating student with an
outstanding record in the study of
marketing and who shows promise for
future contributions to the field this
year's recipient is Gina Wang
and lastly I would like to welcome Peter
Liang a Columbia Alumni Association
Board member and a CBS alum from the
class of 2008 to the stage to present
the Campbell award this award is
presented annually to a graduating
student at each school who shows
exceptional leadership and Columbia
Spirit as exemplified by the late Bill
Campbell who is chair emeritus
University trustee and outstanding
alumnus and CAA co-founder this year's
recipient is Josh Barrett
it is now my great pleasure to introduce
your student government co-presidents to
begin their remarks first up is Lindy
Gould who will be followed by Jeff
silver
[Applause]
thank you so much salon it's an honor to
stand up here with you today two years
ago I drove to this campus for my
Columbia MBA orientation I was terrified
I remember
sobbing begging my husband Willie to
turn back my imposter syndrome felt
insurmountable what was I thinking going
for an MBA I was a middle school teacher
worse yet I was a theater major but I
came to business school because I
believe that business leaders have a
unique role to play in changing our
world for the better reducing poverty
curtailing climate change and creating a
more just and equitable Society but how
can I do any of these things if I didn't
feel confident enough to survive in a
world of cool businesspeople that's you
guys and then I met you my astronauts
ballers my ballers my captain's like my
dinos my entertainers fireballs
gladiators
hippies my extra-spicy
yeehaw
and zombies the most passionate
brilliant thoughtful diverse group of
people I could have ever hoped to
encounter you quickly taught me that I
wasn't alone each of you brought your
own insecurities and strengths to our
shared experiences and more than that
each of you had some unique way that you
are planning to also make the world a
more positive place the world that we
are graduating into is not an easy one
professor Todd Fick our change
management expert and today's recipient
of the Singhvi prize for scholarship in
the classroom called it a VUCA world
volatile uncertain complex and ambiguous
a Columbia MBA of the past might have
been able to pick a career and hold it
for life for us the very jobs we just
spent two years recruiting for might not
exist in a decade but professor dick
encourages us not to panic instead we
should ride these waves and help write
the next chapter of management
leadership so let's make this next
chapter of leadership one that harks
back to why so many of us came here in
the first place to improve this world
for all people and if you doubt your
ability to influence the world in a
positive way ask some of the friends and
a family who came here today to see you
graduate they came here because they
know the world needs visionary inclusive
socially minded leaders and they are
betting on you to be one of them so
class of 2019 here are three ways that
we can all commit to be those visionary
leaders and ultimately leave this world
a better place than we found it
first rather than fearing James let's
run towards it we've already driven
change at CBS as club presidents on
Cluster boards as teaching assistants
and tutors as members of the Student
Government Executive Board in
internships and more now it's time for
us to go out and drive that same change
in the world
let's also step up to the challenge of
continually remembering the people whose
lives are affected by our leadership
living in New York and attending an Ivy
League institution it can be easy for us
to lose sight of the people and families
who are most affected by our decisions
to acquire and disrupt and expand into
new markets let's be those leaders that
remember the factory owner the factory
worker and the small business owner and
their kids and communities when you make
decisions that are good for business but
also respect the dignity and livelihood
of all people second let's get involved
in the public discourse one of my
favorite classes here at CBS was modern
political economy taught by Professor
bae Horton
yeah we all like that class the purpose
of this class is to help MBA students
understand predict adapt to and shape
the world around us because if we don't
other people will and not necessarily
our best interests or society's best
interests so let's take professor
Hortons remarks to heart and get
involved civically this can mean doing
pro bono consulting work like Matt
McConnell's work with the National Park
Service teaching business skills like
entrepreneurship and financial literacy
to those who most stand to benefit like
Doran CEO Kenny Thompson Martin Repco
and Amelia Munson's work with women who
are incarcerated at Taconic correctional
facility raising money for important
causes like Kristin Cummings hike of the
Grand Canyon to raise money for the
Crohn's and Colitis foundation
campaigning for political candidates
with strong people-oriented values like
Stella Dinka fish
or perhaps one day even running for
office ourselves finally take advantage
of the potential for business to be a
force for social good I asked some maybe
the ways in which you've seen business
do practical sustainable good over the
last two years and here's what you said
Catherine Bergstrom said at Columbia I
had the opportunity to participate in a
course called bridging the American
divide which brought 26 CBS students to
Youngstown Ohio to learn about the
challenges facing this post
manufacturing region in Youngstown I saw
firsthand how business leaders were
collaborating with city leaders and
civilians to fight for the
revitalization and well-being of their
town Selene Toronto I'm committed to
protecting our planet by integrating
sustainable eco-friendly practices into
our businesses so I took on an end
semester internship at a startup focused
on plastic reduction within cleaning
supplies and jon-christopher said over
but John Christopher said over winter
break of this year I was honored to
bring eleven of my classmates from five
different countries to visit the ODA
Foundation a nonprofit I founded that
focuses on providing health and
education services to marginalized
communities in Nepal I'm inspired by my
classmates who regularly look beyond
their own self-interest to ensure that
they as Future Business Leaders
understand and engage with the
challenges in our world each of you has
your own story like this and I'm so
inspired by how we as a community are
thinking about business leadership is
something that gives rather than takes I
am confident that we are going to
disrupt business itself making it a
consistent force for social good
before I came to Colombia I didn't think
I could change the world I didn't think
I was smart enough experienced enough or
confident enough but because of the last
few years and what I've seen you all
accomplished already
I now know it's possible for me and for
each of you and I especially know it's
possible because the biggest change from
August 20th 2017 to today May 19th 2019
is that now we have each other as
resources future colleagues and lifelong
friends we came to CBS to be changed and
now it's our time to be the change
makers class of 2019 let's go change the
world thank you
[Applause]
thank you and now I am so excited to
introduce you all to my co-president
here at CBS we don't run on a slate with
another president so we were elected
separately and I did not know this man
before I was elected but I can honestly
say I could not have asked for a better
counterpart email editor person to say
Lindy let's just slow down and think
about this for a second human in the
entire world so please join me in
welcoming my dear friend Jeff silver
[Applause]
Lindy thank you so much it's been an
absolute privilege to serve this year
with you class of 2019 over the last two
years we've learned how to leverage
baton Eze and analyze income statements
we've built professional networks and
lifelong relationships and most
importantly in the words of Rachel
Wasser our instagrams are far better
than we arrived at school despite our
diverse interests and perspectives
there's one universal activity that all
CBS students have practiced small talk
what are you recruiting for where are
you from are you gonna rugby happy hour
tonight oh and what are you recruiting
for again yes we've had a lot of small
talk but here at CBS we've also had a
lot of big talk deep talk real talk big
talk is the authenticity and
vulnerability you find in CVS matters
it's showing up to a randomly assigned
supper club and staying until 3:00 a.m.
because no one wants to leave it's going
on a chasing trip or PSL retreat with a
few people you know and coming back best
friends
and with eight new venmo requests big
talk at CBS has taught me two main
things first hearing other stories
expands our capacity for empathy it
improves our understanding of others
diverse perspectives as well as our own
lives I think about Sarah wins
school-wide CBS matters her story about
growing up in Vietnam with their entire
family living in a single tiny room how
cultural pressures of gender roles
spurred Sarah to fight for a better life
and pursue education opportunities in
Finland I think about my global
immersion in Ghana and hearing how much
it meant to lancelot Drummond's
to consult Firth he's worthy of all that
how much it meant to Lancelot Drummond's
to consult for a thriving company whose
entire leadership team was black
something that he a black man himself
had never experienced big talk has made
me see how everyone has stories and even
with all the super impressive people
here everyone has scars in turn CBS has
empowered me to take ownership of my own
story how the absence of a father has
led me to gravitate towards male mentors
how during high school I moved out of my
house to live with a faculty couple and
how my past leaves me to embrace
community and team oriented settings
where they're walking on to the football
team in college or joining the rugby
club here at CBS I've learned that to be
successful leaders we must first
understand the great and challenging
parts of ourselves and each other
second the process of engaging with big
talk sharing ourselves with one another
Foster's relationships and
transformative transformative
connections it leads to my spending
Christmas and Michael per annex house
where his family made me where his
family made me my first ever
personalized stalking it leads to me
Stan
beside miles bloom at the best man it is
wedding next spring so what is it about
CBS that Foster's his depth of
engagement it starts with a culture of
support psychological research refers to
this a sense of belonging think about
our first day of orientation as I walk
past low library right behind me and
turn the corner towards yours hall
I could hear CBS before I could see it
the growing sounds of clapping cheering
hollering is this where I'm going
then hordes of dancing blue polos burst
into sight welcoming us to our new home
cheering set the tone for CBS experience
of encouragement and inclusion in fact
during orientation we were instructed
how's it here who's the best cussed
xxxxX
I had arrived now on our last day it
seems only fitting that once again we'll
be walking up stairs this time up this
platform and with a better background I
might add again to the sounds of
cheering it's hard to top enthusiasm of
peer advisor extraordinaire Zack stone
leading the charge on the megaphone
slapping high-fives and singing Taylor
Swift I can see he's ready to join in
right now
but today the cheering will be amplified
by our families and supporters in the
crowd those who have seen us far less
over the last two years than we've seen
our cluster mates career advisors and
boxes of stroke O's pizza yet those here
today in many ways were always with us
and are often the subject of those big
talk conversations you're a part of our
stories as we a part of yours thank you
for being here
[Applause]
while it's CBS we've gained more than
just pounds and free pizza and happy
hour drinks in the spirit of Big Talk
I asked classmates what they will miss
most about this place
Rahul Goyal said the ease and frequency
with which a quick hi turned into a
meaningful and deep conversation I
promise I didn't tell him to say that
ste Angela said hearing people share
deep and personal stories at CBS Matters
and frequent opportunities to do things
outside of my comfort zone for full
disclosure
Stian also provided unprompted a list of
things that he will not miss in
including Urist le FOMO and trying to
find a time for group meetings with
second years my favorite response came
from cluster chair Arthur sukumaran what
I'll miss most about CBS Arjun said is
seeing classmates turn into job hunters
turn into happy hour legends turn into
CBS Mathers softies turn into late-night
karaoke abominations turn into best
friends all within a 24-hour span
[Applause]
in the spirit of origin let's move
forward and we all know what that means
forward and continue to reap the rewards
of big talk let's push through the first
minutes about the weather and delays on
the one train to ask each other what
really matters let's go forward with
that same attitude of support and just
like on that first day of orientation
let's continue to cheer for one another
up these stairs today and out into the
world class of 2019 congratulations
[Applause]
Thank You Lindy and Jeff both for your
remarks and for your leadership and
partnership this year I hope you know
you leave CBS better than you found it
and I'm really proud to have worked with
you as we move to start to the
recognition of our candidates I'd like
to take a few minutes to honor a beloved
classmate in November 2018 cluster a and
the entire CBS family lost a wonderful
human being in Eugene Mike losing anyone
is hard but losing a student and someone
so young is absolutely heartbreaking but
I saw this community come together to
support his family and one another today
I want you to all remember your brother
Eugene a brother who was a loving
husband a doting father a friend in a
very proud and active a astronaut he was
smart he was a passionate entrepreneur a
caring and giving tutor but most
importantly he was thoughtful and he was
kind and we will forever hold his memory
dear please join me for a moment of
silence in loving memory of Eugene Mike
Thank You Eugene we will carry your
memory and spirit with us today and
forever thank you all so much
and we will now begin our president
presentation of candidates now
presenting cluster a is son of Azad a
[Applause]
Sakshi Agarwal Juan Pablo altamirano da
he's album Maria fable IDO de merde
Katherine Bergstrom
Jonathan buns Alan Chen site H in Daniel
child
Sam sialic and Korie all Alexander L
gave a cheek
Anisha das Marcella - Shawn Spencer
pleasure
Dana glicks Berg Kimberly goal
Seth Goldwasser Anna heightened Seth
what hit record Jade who aundrea Hugh
Birds Julianne hammelburg Chris Young
niveditha Kohli
David Jacob collage Zig
Rohan Kumar Edwin Lee joy serenely
winterly all light Gloria long Joe Meyer
Michelle McCauley Philip Meier Sachi
Nakano ty Han win
Carolyn Haley Novus Monday at p.m.
Ratana Wang thought in Poddar Evan
wrapkin Brian Richmond Gregory Roberson
aldose Kanani Sam Jin Ryan Schneider
Eleanor - Donnie
Jenny thappa egg a took Eddie
[Applause]
garnet vanie Carlos V R Monica VIN way
LaSalle Barca Lauren Warshofsky
Christopher wells Catherine Williams
bridge now presenting cluster b GE HMA
Ashley mln Michael Allison Alyssa Aiden
Nissan eigen Jeffrey Burke yeonbok ta
Stella Bing kovitch Stephen Chow Camila
bueno Cardozo ANCA cha-da marc shahboz
vada Cachola writer Cleary Jeffrey
Cooper Elena Cortez
Patricia Craig Alex freed Andrew
Giffen's hi mega Mesa Elizabeth F
Goodstein Belle goo JC hey C Mon Hill
Alison Horton P soon Wong Lucy M Jackson
David cow
[Music]
Josh keema and puja a collie Georgie
cuprous ve Eric Lee she'll in Scotland
stone
Pedro Machado Gillian McPherson Desmond
McGowan James McNeill Alexandre Milstein
[Applause]
Santiago Molteni Alexandra Morgan Welch
Amanda knee Kelly O'Connor
[Music]
Shivam pappu Elizabeth passante Daniel
Pesek Luiz Fernando 'pretty Ethan
Schmidt
[Applause]
Jill skov iner aishwarya Sharma angeleka
Singh mark Andrew Skinner
Matthew Stevenson are Junsu Kumaran
Ethan baseman Ernesto Quinto vampa Borg
barrage Bora Lilly way Elizabeth Weiland
[Music]
aundrea Wyman Wong you are none Jong now
presenting cluster C Luis Guillermo
Acosta Sunil
Ryan Ahuja Cynthia alum dunya
balasubrahmanyam Alexandra Barry
[Music]
Gabrielle bomb re burg Sebastian Bruno
mallanna's Katelyn Margaret Butler
Daniel James Castelli Athena Cheng John
Sung Jung
[Applause]
Christian coats drew Cornell Jessica qui
Charlie drain Brendan Earl
Zachary fury Ferguson the zeglen gal
badrock William gang where Mariano
Gonzalez Kayla Cabrera
Adam Boren Patrick Griffin
ja Atty gulick Michael horn Shivani
ha Jayla Angelina whoo
Reuben had Yulin Bradford drew Kahneman
Sebastian lotta P Gwen Lee Hyun soo limb
Cassandra Lopez Kelly Lundy Peter Lydon
Janelle Marte Eric McCarthy Jamie marula
Natasha Nayar Brittany Ateneo odigma
[Music]
Taylor palanca Blake Peterson
Christopher Pisani Lydia Quinn Venkat
Raja Raman Clemente Reyes Ratana
connor ryan yo nice a bog from a Shetty
sharra sing Marcus
singleton hunter pain smiley Connor
Stovall Selene Tarrant chase Tucker
Peter one David way Emily Whitaker Ron
whoo nah Alma Yehezkel Amanda Zhang now
presenting cluster D Erica Abramson Matt
L Joshua and ER March jam sheer endless
area mio asset on E
[Music]
Dara bloom Benny Burstein Branagh
chattri Lisa Chen Randall chin April
chai Jose Cloutier Anya
Clifford mayor Cohen
Danielle Rome Italy delaqua Greg dorje
day Spivey
Hana dul Jen Lindley gray Driscoll
Jillian Mercer Dudek matthew ellis
michael slum Kevin Yoshiaki Gallagher
Mitchell Gora dokkan ancho Gulati Oscar
Henschel Morgan Holmes
Keita Ito Nick Carr
Elizabeth Kelly DeWolf Eric Kogut minsu
hyung
Ricardo silver Oh leaker all Jun Li
jo-lynn Jeffrey Lothian Benjamin McCabe
[Applause]
Gabriel Metzker will Miller Cirrus Maj
day he Amelia
Noel Monson Gladys
Amelia and a gray Kelly O'Brien Olaf
Aloha
Olie saga Valentina
Carlos again Alexa Picciotto Adi Prasad
Justin
Reggie Laura Rogers Eitan Shindell Haim
John icky saccharine Sid Sheinberg
Brandon Shang Brian Spiegel
Vincent Siew Maeve see Vanitas
Naomi tut hope nivedita Venkatesh
Matthew Weinberg Jasper woo Frank
yo DJ when Jang chaeri Kuan Hsiao Mao
presenting cluster e Justine Aronoff
Daniel Bateman mark Beloit Sasha bender
Oh Ramone Blanco the yard
Tim bid 'ln Pedro Canales Alicia Chen
[Music]
Jim how you Chen Archon cheer achieve at
Melissa Cole Alexis crank of itch
Brandon Dillo
[Applause]
Alex Ettinger a Killa friend Emma
Forster Alisa Goldberg said good men
Klaus boot pond pari Gupta Mesa Haddad
Eric herzfeld Elizabeth Hirsch Dennis ho
Shane Humphrey
Aditya Jane
Emily Aaron Joplin Edwin Kim ill Sheen
Brian Klock Karen Langley Harper Evans
Lee Helen Lee Han Lee Oh si Han Liu
Genevieve Loomis Robin lore yang Liu
[Applause]
Samantha
Alexandre Martin Brandon McCampbell
Vikram Menon Mark Miller
Chad Morin Ruchi nan de Amanda Nicklin
[Music]
David Nigri Paul Petersen veeraiah's fry
Lankan Hanna written Kimberly Roberts
Brandon Roy hey soos Salas
Miguel Sanchez dalaran mahi cos Yosuke
Sato hope Scott fig Vijay Singh Jay
Stewart Bruce son
Verity Sylvester Sriram Trek utam
Florence tie under attack Adele Alden
Leisha one Michael Wooten link Shao Yong
grace ye Jason Yoon
Julia's swag
now presenting cluster F Yoon on Rodrigo
a lien Aditi Bhatia Arthur Bruce Oh
Tommy Chan
Andy sanchow minjin Chen Natalia
Kristensen Terry Cunningham
Ryan Darren Criss Denon neeti Daris max
Estevez Caroline Brooke Freedman again
get her baby and gone Elizabeth ruber
Victoria goon Brad Headley Matthew hawk
Hauser
Cyrus Wong Jing Jing Huang alexandrina
Ivanova Alexander kasi Andrew Lagoo
Natalie lamb Sean Lim Justin Lipton
[Music]
Allison Taylor listen al Thomas Lou
Sarah long Greg Marvin
Matthew McConnell Kyle Maguire
Diana Thompson McCain Catherine McKenna
[Applause]
Ariel Merrick
Shruti nyuk
Kenny O'Brien g1 Oh Kendall Harker
Joseph ronni le party no demanded Cooper
[Applause]
Jeanette's Paulino Christopher Perkins
Adam Clayton Powell
Catherine Princess Valley Jorge Ramirez
[Applause]
Solomon ravage jody rosen slide set
Ruben Austin Shaw Samantha Smith jack
spits in Candice Xue Jian Anton Elena
van Cova
[Applause]
shreya Gandhi Vora Irene Wang max Wong
Lee West Caroline Whitmer David Chang
Daniella zuluaga now presenting cluster
G Alexandra Curran Abingdon Thomas
emerald dimple Bonzo
Brendan Barnwell Jane bailenson Maria
Natalia bond Danza Kevin brenes David
ciao Guillermo Chapman Michael cherry
jon-christopher
[Applause]
Anthony Kolbert Beth Erin Connolly she
loved a Andrew Doherty
Mook are UN gone to more Anastacio
Gordon
[Music]
Rebecca Greenberg McCool Gupta Charlie
Hannah Chris Hong Daniel Hussein Sonya M
Elena
Ivanova Asher Jacobs mark Joan
Pierre upon JIT nom plung James Crocker
chun-li Jay Lee
tami-lynn
[Music]
Hongbo Lou Kristin Marie London John
Molloy
Angela Antonieta Makati Nia tellin
McGrath Brooke
Ashley Miller Stephanie Alicia McGowan
[Applause]
mark Mosby
Alexander DiNunzio merace Miriam most me
[Applause]
Rebecca
Ashley Nathan Leah
Oh hundred Paul leads Pierce John place
Ted
Preston poom
Naveen karashi Gaby Redondo Chris
Robicheaux Oliver Salman Michelle
shishun Anand
Saachi done and um Michael Stern Alexi
Thomas Mandy Tong so Andrew tsukamoto
Tim turducken off Akanksha Vasudeva
Francisco Ventura Monica VR John White
Ling
yay Patrick ye Jake shoe now presenting
cluster H Courtney Andrews taka hasta
Nelly Beach Gilly bergman melody
bickersteth vikram Bishnoi Peter Brown
[Applause]
Zhi Sheng Tai hey soos you Chet why yes
Aaron Allen Kenard Celyn Rachel chase
sue Fung fun Lancelot Drummond's
Alexander churner Jess Cole
hailey Nicole Cox shy J'son Feld
Sid Ghosh
Jessica gimble Alexander golden Mary
Lillian home Charlotte hey Don holder
Allison Buckman hunter prob hey Joshi
Nadia
Co so Adam curb its Jessica Langman
Jessie Laura SH Howard Lee Ally John Lee
Jo glue Wei Lin
Patrick Manning
[Applause]
Allison McCarty Ryan John McKenna Steven
Molino Nicolai Mohan Anna more holy Jose
Lorenzo Osman yeah
Andres Polaski Samara Pollack Rana
protential e Cory prot Danny Rock pooja
Nicole
Suzanne Riaz e Gregory reads Peter roll
Bennett Reznik
Robert H shouts Dave shaker Shang yang
she ankeet Siobhan Rabab sing Patrick
tsofen Jane
Dorsey Taylor such it Dooley Claudia
Vera des flow Marshall Verde Christine
Wang Ron young wrong
Robert Steven wiser
Elizabeth wills
Wilson Yong Yong any Jiang now
presenting cluster X say Yunnan
Darla by yeah Alexander burka Meyer
miles bloom Arthur Barret Sean KY seeing
you Chan young mojo Taylor Christmas
Joseph Chand
Patricia Ynez de carvalho Baros larger
ayo video Gautier denno yella
Rahul domani Tim Donovan jr. Christian
HR Jessica French Guillermo Gerardo Lika
Sanna Himani Margaret hung Harrison
Cardin Meredith Kernan harsh chemical
[Applause]
Yogesh Kumar
Francine Lee
Matthew Lee Gemma Lim Frederico SP Nia
Lopez Lewis Ferdinand man Bennett may
rod Patrick Magee shaadi Mubarak Sara
Nguyen Steph otter spor Michael / an egg
Matthew Petersen do we find Monica Pinto
Bosto a meme ape right Davide police say
Christopher rich Gruber
Michelle Rio de Janeiro Ruka Alessandra
Sanchi louis santa cruz juan raphael
Suppan go Vanessa bogna
Nicholas tiger Kenneth J Thompson Joseph
Tom Elena a gay Torres lot Avon oom
Nicholas Vega Yona Jackson vicar
Regan Wallace Lawrence Wong
he's a van visor Nicholas Whitehead
Jennifer woo
[Music]
Tilly Joseph Otto whiter Jody Chiang
Brian Young Bing Chang Laurent lung leo
[Music]
hyung
[Applause]
now presenting cluster why Claudia
buy-ins Carolyn Ruth ball
[Music]
Peter Bonilla Ratana gone kid Morris
Breitbart my Elaine powder Giovanna
Campania Gustavo Canas alice-chan Andre
simmerman Bradford Randolph Corbin Kevin
:
Lawson Curtis Fabio DiGregorio Salomon
Diaz
Franklin Floyd Kristen Forrester Jose
Antonio Garcia Rosa
Nandhini guard Emir guy
David Goldberg
[Music]
[Applause]
Stian Gullah Molly Farrow heart
Chihiro Hashimoto Rohan Hegde Riley hi
Alexandra Hoyer Albert young Jeffrey
Johnson - Kurt von bonded kayo jae-hyun
Cole
jake'll our Jung Hyun Lee Barbara
Machado Craig Massey
Elizabeth Matthew Julian medleys Eric
Morden Cory Moser Homer mullet soham
Narang Sharad Patel Marc porn
Julia Cristina hribal Martine repco a
mere Oh Agatha on see Daniel Gary Ruben
[Music]
[Applause]
Mariana Ruiz UNAM sarangi Alison shear
Andrew silky Marek slobotnik Danis
mullion Kyle text or data tight Imran
Nava Sawa
Nick say Cameron Willard see way William
shoo
Chloe Chang hai Mei Alfonso zbel de
ayala Thomas peas older now presenting
cluster Z Sarah Adler Sydney on Nisha
bhiwani Jacopo Bellini Alison Callahan
Lorenzo Cassidy knee
ilaria Kato's e le Charbel Ivanov
Dhingra thoradine
Carlos Dominguez Antigua Yvette drew
Maga damn EF key
[Applause]
Anthony Ella smart Donnie le hui'
Lodovico Ferrari Oh Sammy for the
stretching down
Sophie Academy and Maxwell Glassman
Robbie Griffin Christian Guillermo Kyle
Hartman parese ahemadi look Wang ah
[Applause]
she's Jane
Logan Jeff's boom Patimkin goon MA
Angelica chorim Voki Nick Kumar air
Lancer Rebecca Levin
Kevin's you fail you
Yoshi ah who mission boot ish
[Applause]
Anabelle Morgan
Jacob mo aru naga by raava were veena
pani Federico of man Christopher Pass
eco Taylor Pierce Jose Luis Pinto Bosco
Alexandra Rashi Nina Tov on ready insa
REMS ins Gustavo Santos and I McEntee
Schiller been Schnitzer Jaime Schwartz
Antonio Seco Mondi Raghav says Juan Jose
Silva Charmin Ananya shriek on Pavan
Surabhi Ron Tate's anand krishna tamari
see mercury 10 Daniel Joseph Tong
kovitch Paul 20
Borgia hurt the son Chelsea Wang won how
long Shirley Wang Tom wethington James
Walker warehouser Florence we Jaya
Andres Hakeem levy now presenting award
recipients Evan Einstein Beaulieu a day
yay
Kristen Ames Cummings
Jacinta James Joseph Lynch
Dornan CEO Catherine to Santa's then
Hassan
Zachary stone
Rahul Goyal Sanchi la da Cindy chin ken
ran st belief Ruiz
[Applause]
viviana Qatari Sandra Lucia
Charlotte and Schumacher Porter Bora her
perler or ERT Catherine bed Kowski
Lauren schmear mark coats linkit ah
immortal uru Zachary Gober collect Sola
Carly Roth
Tina Wang Joshua Barrett
now presenting stage participants
Brianna Lachey Sadler
Lindy cold
[Applause]
Jeffrey silver
let's give everybody another big round
of applause I am perfectly aware that I
am now all that stands between you and a
reception with your friends and family
so I will be brief just two things one a
message from me and another a message
for you message from me is to paraphrase
General MacArthur that old Dean's never
die
they don't even fade away so I look
forward to seeing you at events for
Columbia and in your lives in the future
you mean the world to me
into this institution message for you
I'm confident that as you were preparing
to come here today when you expressed
your dream to somebody probably one of
those somebodies expressed some
skepticism that the world going forward
is not so bright I want you to tell
those people to go to Cathedral City
California and read Frank Sinatra's
tombstone because it says what I think
for you and what I think for Columbia
Business School it's really simple the
best is yet to come
congratulations class of 2019
- to friends and family the graduates
and the stage participants are going to
recess toward ensel Plaza please wait
for them and then follow them if you
don't know where Ansel Plaza is and I'm
sure you don't just watch one guy in red
and hundreds in blue and you'll get
there
congratulations
[Applause]
again family and friends on the east
side of the lawn we ask that you please
wait for the graduates to exit before
exiting your seating area those of you
on the west side of the lawn we ask that
you please exit promptly so we may
prepare for our next ceremony please be
sure to join us on Ansel Plaza for our
reception thank you
[Music]